THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO SAID
THIS ABOUT THE SITUATION.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
PLAYED.
OKAY?
WE'RE GOING TO HOPEFULLY
MAKE A DEAL.
WE DON'T THAT'S FINE.
UNITED STATES IN THE PAST
WAS PLAYED LIKE A FIDEL.
FIDDLE.
KNOWN GOING IN AND NOBODY
KNEW WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
WE WILL COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION.
IF WE DON'T, WE LEAVE THE
ROOM WITH GREAT RESPECT.
WE LEAVE THE ROOM OR WE KEEP
IT GOING.
THIS ISN'T LIKE PAST
ADMINISTRATION WE DON'T PLAY
GAMES.
>> Judge: JOINING US NOW IS
LIEUTENANT COLONEL ALLEN
WEST.
FORMER TREASURY DEPARTMENT
ANALYST ARE A TELLING GAS
AND FORMER BRIGADIER GENERAL
TONY AT A TIME ATTACHMENT
ALLEN, I'M GOING TO START
WITH YOU.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WERE
ACTUALLY IN THE MILITARIZED
ZONE.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE THAT KIM
JONG UN HAS MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT MOON OF SOUTH
KOREA AND ACTUALLY STEPPED
OVER THAT DEMILITARIZED
ZONE?
>> WELL, IT IS GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU, JUDGE.
IN 1995 I WAS STATIONED
THERE WITH THE SECOND
INFANTRY DIVISION.
I REMEMBER HAS A SENIOR
OFFICER SEEING THE TUNNELS
THAT THE NORTH KOREANS HAD
DUG TO TRY TO INFILTRATE IN
SOUTH KOREA.
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HISTO
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HISTI
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HISTC
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HISTM
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HISTN
TODAY WAS HINK CALL MOMENT HIST.
KIM JONG UN HAS BEEN A
PERSON YOU CANNOT TRUST.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE SYSTEMS
AND SANCTIONS IN PLACE.
VERIFY ANYTHING HE SAYS HE
IS GOING TO DO.
BECAUSE HISTORY WILL TEACH
US, NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN SAT
BACK DOWN WITH HITLER AND
SIGNED THE MUNICH ACCORD AND
LATER ON HITLER SAID IT WAS
JUST A PIECE OF PAPER.
>> Judge: MORGAN, THOSE WHO
SAY WE HAVE REACHED A POINT
THOUGHT
NOOUGHT
NOWUGHT
NOW THT
NOW THAT IS ONLY DUE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE REFERENCED IT A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
A LOT OF NAME-CALLING AND
FEW OTHER THINGS SEVERAL
MONTHS BACK ROCKET MAN AND
ALL THE OTHER BACK AND
FORTH.
THAT REALLY DID LEAD OR
CREATE THE FOUNDATION FOR
THIS MEETING BETWEEN
PRESIDENT MOON AND KIM JONG
UN.
COULD YOU AGREE?
>> ABSOLUTELY, JUDGE.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
DESERVES A TON OF CREDIT FOR
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
AND YOU ARE EVEN SEEING SOME
OF HIS BIGGEST CRITICS GIVE
HIM CREDIT AS WELL.
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT
WENT OUT OF HIS WAY TO SAY
THAT THE POLICIES OF THE
PRESIDENT IS WHAT HAS LED
TOWARDS TODAY.
I WILL SAY THOUGH THOUGH
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
GENERAL JUST SAID.
WE VIEW EVERYTHING WITH
SKEPTICISM WHEN IT COMES TO
KIM JONG UN.
TODAY WE SAW FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE NORTH KOREA LEADER
STEP ON THE SOUTH KOREA NEL
SOIL.